he sent me like a voicemail about like
three in the morning or something was
like
pedro
wow
how do you know this is the right path
for you
when it's like
i'm exhausted like this was last night i
was sitting there
i had started working at like 9 30 in
the morning which is so late for an
artist let me let me just say uh 9 30 in
the morning
uh i started working it was like
i think it was like 1 30 at night like i
realized i was like where am i i didn't
like
think i was just you know working and
editing and
little promos for the movie and like
thinking about other script ideas and
doing it all uh
those are the moments i'm reminded where
i'm like oh i
will never do anything else other than
like create
um
i call it like time travel moments
you know where you're just doing like 16
hour days and
um
whether
you
feel
like crap or not uh you wake up the next
day and do it again
that's how i know
do the days tend to blend in
to one another for sure if i didn't
travel so much i would
i probably still think i'm like 19
i feel like i feel like it's good
seasonal chapters of being like ah when
i went to new york that was july you
know um yeah
would you say you're obsessed with
storytelling
i would i would i think i'm so obsessed
with storytelling i can't
choose just one specific field in
storytelling
and
i never will
what makes you obsessed
think there's a lot of adventures in my
own life um that i
think are just
too good not to share
i i've had a fun i've had a fun life um
and whether it's those specific
adventures i think there's moments that
can connect uh
people and me to people
uh
that are worth sharing you know and i
think the coolest part about making
movies is that it's brought me so much
closer to my friends like talking about
each other's movies or talking about
someone else's movies
it's always a great way to
just communicate and relate and
and feel and um
yeah i've gotten way closer to my family
like just by doing this movie and
i've changed my mind about you know my
relationship with my family like a
million times like throughout this movie
um and i
probably would have never had those
conversations till a day that
me and all of my family are dead like i
would have never talked about some of
the stuff that i have because of movies
did they know you were writing the
script
with fabio yes yeah yeah so
um
yeah i can't remember when oh no yeah
so fabio and i were we're talking about
shooting uh shooting some ideas like
that could be
doable for us
shot several shorts together and that's
some
really dumb sketch comedy stuff
uh
that some of it i still think is funny
uh but um
we were trying to figure out what
resources we could take in our lives and
and make something out of it and
apartments were one of those things so
we started talking about a lot of uh
apartment ideas
and uh fabio didn't know it at the time
but my dad had uh had lung cancer uh
when i was like 14 and i think it was
like
23 or 24 when he started talking about
my dad dad maybe 23. um and so he never
knew about any of that and i started
talking about oh my dad had lung cancer
he called me i hadn't seen him in years
like he was on in peru i was in qatar
uh he had said hey man uh i was like
shocked he was even calling in the first
place and was like hey
what's up
and he's like nothing much
i'm dying and i have a month left to
live
and i was like
what um
and he told me that he had an apartment
in peru that i had no idea even existed
um
kind of a shabby
crumbly apartment
uh and
that at the time
he said your name is going to be put on
it because i'm not going to last much
longer and you're going to have to
manage it and i was 14. totally
unqualified i didn't even know where it
was or
even really speak
great enough spanish to manage that um
and so
uh
luckily in real life he actually had his
lung removed
uh surgically removed he had lung cancer
and survived by like a sliver of fate so
i went on for like two three months
being like oh my dad's dead like my
dad's dead i'm an apartment manager now
uh
you know life was on its head for sure
and um
luckily throughout that experience like
later on when i when i was um
becoming a little bit more of an adult i
moved to peru and got to spend a lot of
time with him and
uh
sort of get closer in that way and uh
and so
our apartment ideas the low budget kind
of resource filmmaking and that idea
sort of met um
and uh
yeah it's really special and it's weird
because people usually think like my
dad's
dead rightfully so but he's actually
still alive
he's actually still alive uh we don't
really communicate in a traditional way
as often and he's a thick peruvian
accent you know he lives in another
world for sure um but he actually saw
the movie like a month ago he knew i was
making a movie i don't think he knew
exactly that it was kind of
greatly inspired by him
and
and like i kind of mentioned it it
brought us closer together i think there
was a lot of he sent me like a voicemail
about like three in the morning or
something was like
pedro
wow
so
i love you wow you know it's just like
it's the greatest voice memo ever
you know uh
and
yeah i'm sure we'll talk about it more
that's awesome yeah
yeah because some people might be like
you know you're talking about family
things and maybe it's too close for them
to see and yeah so that's that's awesome
that you had that
experience that was a cool moment for
sure
did you envision yourself as this like
manager you know
yeah
it's like i can't even
manage myself i still can't
uh let alone an apartment my lord uh
yeah
nope
i would love to see a 14 year old coming
to collect late rent yeah that'd be
awesome good luck with that
yeah not sure how well that would go
over but right
yeah i think i think too just to add on
to that making movies like that that are
kind of personal in that way the cool
thing about it is that
they can mean so much more as time goes
on like
you know i look back at some of the
movie and i'm like oh that that's a line
i wrote or
something where i'm like oh changed my
mind about that you know
but
like
that movie's gonna be really special i
think in five years and in 10 years and
20 years you know
um and i can't wait to show my kids one
day that movie you know or like my
sister my i don't think my sister's
seen the movie yet she's 19 and like was
even kind of
i think
more distant from my dad at the time um
because they got divorced when i was
young so she was like really young
and uh
i can't wait till she sees it and like
you know i don't know if she'll like
totally get it but like
you know
watch it marietta
did she live in qatar with you she yeah
she lived in qatar with me so we were in
seattle she was born in seattle then me
and my sister my mom and step-dad
actually
moved to qatar and then i split up from
them and moved to peru halfway through
high school and then
yeah then my sister moved to germany
with my mom and then china with my mom
and now my mom's in brazil she's a
teacher and just gets all these cool
opportunities to teach across the world
so
that's how i kind of got roped into the
world
very cool yeah you said that you had so
many fun experiences that you wanted to
share them in stories
is there someone's life that you look at
where you've watched their biopic and
you think wow
like
hunter s thompson or somebody where
you're just like
if i could have lived that life
may or may not have been good who knows
but yeah i mean you know what's so funny
about that like i've sort of
i'm starting to change my perspective on
this and we talked about this a little
bit with like seattle and these great
artists that may have not
stuck around because of whatever reason
drugs or
or just themselves um and
i think
it's funny because immediately when you
say that like most of the people i'm
like
i look up to
are dead which is crazy like prematurely
like like heath ledger
or you know uh
i mean like
you know kurt cobain for various reasons
uh
which is just so interesting that i
think
i don't know if this is everyone but i
know a lot of young people who idolize
people who've died young um
and maybe there's
they kind of
i think i was vicariously like living
through their wild life and
and
and the fact that they're great artists
like like heath ledger for example
there's a documentary i think it's
called i am heath
uh i should know the title because i've
seen it like 20 times like literally i
went through a phase where i was just
like on and i was like writing like
uh
just constantly um
so
i don't know why that is um
[Music]
and i think there's something to that
it's almost weird just about humans
um
but the older i get
the more i realize there's definitely a
balance you know
um and i think it's almost kind of
a little questionable to
to blindly i mean idolize anyone but let
alone like
these bright burning souls you know uh
without really asking yourself like
damn is everything that they've gone
through
worth living like that you know i don't
know
yeah i remember when i turned 27 someone
said like i hope you don't join the 27
club
and i kind of went down this rabbit hole
of like researching and i was like oh
wow you know i mean janice joplin like
so many different people amy winehouse
at that time she wasn't famous but
you know just different people and you
go you it's easy to see their life as
like
um i don't even know the word for it
it's tragic and it's beautiful but at
the same time yeah it's very sad yeah no
it's very
rockstar-esque and i mean even myself
like
just maybe this is the seattle in me or
or the crazy experiences i've gone
through there was definitely like
probably from like the age of 19 to
maybe like 22. i was like
yeah
you know kind of saying it jokingly but
like yeah i'll probably be part of the
27 club or whatever you know like
why would i say that you know like
that's horrible like
uh
[Music]
yeah and now i'm 26
so i'm like oh god no oh no oh my gosh
why did i bring this up i'm sorry this
is weird that we went here okay no no no
it's interesting to me like it's it's so
weird right i mean like you know uh
so
it's important but like i said it's
important to look at like the the
positive in those people's lives and
also like
like how they feel and like what what
was wrong you know
in those moments too you know because
everyone goes through it like
everyone thinks about like crazy
like that you know like the 27 club
or or dying young or
uh any of that and i think that's why
art's so cool because it just like you
know breaks through a lot of that and
forces you to talk about it um that's
why i think it's one of the most
important things on the planet
sure and but the thing is it
it seems cool because there's this
legacy but not everybody's going to be
jim morrison and your life is done yeah
yeah you know and so
and
i think we get easily seduced by that
right right it's yeah
and i say it jokingly but i'm like i
haven't done that much stuff that
wouldn't be good but i mean like you
know like yeah it's no
no i think uh living a long and uh wise
life is very underrated
for sure
yeah